I would argue that I'm still not great
at it and I was borderline atrocious at
it the first 15 to 16 years of my career
you got your perspective don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
everybody it's gary mitrik I was I've
already decided I don't think my team
even knows this that I'm I'm changing
the name of interrupted by yeah because
I just like reading the comments I just
don't I think it triples down on
something I don't want it to so the
reality is is that shows now cancelled
and so now I just interview you know
friends people I'm interested in and and
I have a really dear friend here I
haven't seen in a little while so it's
nice to see you who we're gonna talk
about music and tech and things of that
nature
like I've said you know some of the
people I I know
occasionally reach out like hey I wanna
I want to Yap and and talk about stuff
and I'm like yeah let's do it so no prep
I literally just walked in and and here
we are so why don't you tell the
vaynernation all the people listening
who you are and what you do and then
we'll get into it sure I'm Alana I'm the
founder and CEO of music can you hear me
this better yeah probably been sorry
yeah got it okay so new to this like
whole podcast thing they're gonna teach
me have you ever done a podcast mine
I've done a couple okay good but this is
like a new mic setup I haven't seen them
yeah it's it's we're very crazy around
here no you guys are very like you got
that all together it's all setup I love
it so again I'm Alana I'm the co-founder
and CEO of a company called stem and our
mission is to help artists build
sustainable businesses and when we talk
about artists it's primarily musicians
today and the platform allows a lot of
independent artists to get their music
on Apple and Spotify all the major
platforms and the thing that we do that
no one else does is we automate the
splits on all of the payouts to all the
collaborator so if you see a
collaboration with a bunch of rappers
and it's out independently chances are
it's third step understood so up for
full disclosure I'm an investment in
this company we've known each other a
long time yeah Phil is in the building
which is always nice good to see you
Phil back there who's but staying close
to this investment and so how's it been
going and like like and and when you
talk about distributions like the thing
that most drew me to the opportunity
what is it like four years ago now it'll
be four years ago since I told you about
it five years ago since we started the
company
so no that's a lie five years since I
told you about it for exits so one
things I really liked was the YouTube
ecosystem was super confusing at the
time yeah it still may be that's really
my question has you know it's one thing
to your point when three people to sign
one unsigned collab on a song and it's
super complicated I've learned that
lesson I had a song that I made for
clouds and dirt my sneaker with a gonna
T Arawak and T grizzly that was 38
seconds from being uploaded to Spotify
and launching with my sneaker that died
because it just died how's that been
working and and how has the YouTube
ecosystem worked out and what has
emerged whether it's tick tock or other
things of that nature yeah definitely so
YouTube is still I believe the largest
music platform for streaming right and I
think a big part of it is because it's
totally global Spotify didn't launch
globally initially at least and now it's
continuing to grow that way but when we
started the other property other the
problem I wanted to solve is that there
were all these content creators on
YouTube that were collaborating right
and when they would want to post a video
and it was two different channels they
would post the same video twice and
break the create the views and the
reason they would do that is because
they wanted to each monetize it and so
we thought to ourselves well why don't
we just split the revenue from it right
when you have apps like venmo
and all these others and make it so easy
to send money on the internet if you're
making money on the internet so why
can't you just share it so what happens
now
like if me and Phil both have channels
like there's one pic to air it on theirs
and it just kicks it to the other person
yeah I mean they would've been know each
other the money unless you go through
stem you register the video well you can
post it on both channels it could live
on hundreds of channels we recognize
when the videos being consumed we
collect the revenue from YouTube
directly and then each of you guys have
your own account and you get paid every
month so what's the what's the biggest
learning you've had in last four years
of going from being an executive and
companies and actually give a little
context what was your career prior to
yeah the founding stem so I was one of
the first digital media talent agents in
Hollywood I was brought on as an agent
at the age of 21 which was ridiculous
they would even hire me they but my job
was discovering talent on the internet
and helping them break their concepts
into traditional media so Issa Rae
signed when she had awkward black girl
the channel on YouTube got her book deal
and then we packaged a TV show and sold
it to HBO which was now called insecure
so as being a part of a lot of the
talent that was coming up the internet
who's the first person who signed do you
remember um that's a great question
I actually the Toronto tartare I wish I
don't know but I've had really fun
clients people like Joss Ostrovsky who
you guys know is the fat Jew actually
think one of the first things I signed I
said did you sign him first or was he
already signed and then you know we
signed him because we signed a Twitter
feed called white girl problems I
remember that was like one of the early
kinds I think and he was behind that and
he was close with the writers of that
yeah got it and so we got connected to
him all through that Oh yep that was her
crew it was fun but that's the thing as
I noticed is that more and more
independent creators were making real
money online and building real
businesses and to me it started to
really dispel this notion of a starving
artist right like you and I have similar
roots were both from bobruisk area and
our family is Russian immigrants to the
States and when I told my parents in
high school that I wanted to go to film
school and be a producer they're like
that's a great hobby but not a career
right and that crushed me and so what I
wanted to do is to help artists be able
to not only build careers but businesses
off of doing what they're great at and I
felt like the thing that was really
preventing them was just tools and more
importantly visibility into their
finances so the thing that I've learned
is that it's amazing how how easy it is
for a person to understand their
business when they see their numbers and
numbers with a dollar sign in front of
them yep and like artists have always
been told hey my donors covered I got
this covered like let someone else work
as native and enjoy totally anything
that's [ __ ] yep what was the biggest
surprise to you versus the ideology of
what you thought entrepreneurship was
four years ago to now it's true
realities now that you live in it um
I think it's all about the people around
you right how do you really align people
with your vision and it takes so much
repetition to get people I think to
truly understand what they're rowing
towards as a team and I think that you
at least when I would read about in
books are hear other people talking
about it
it sounded like oh it can't be that hard
but it's actually think the fundamental
thing that you have to get right yeah I
understand I mean it's really funny I
had an employee that's worked at Vayner
for seven years come into my office last
year late last year and say hey like
like super frustrated and the person was
like what are we even doing here and I
started laughing because we had a great
warm relationship and I didn't feel like
it was disrespectful I'm like I have
only repeated 700,000 times to your face
that were building a platform to buy
brands when the economy collapses like
it was like it was like super laughable
but I think it's a really good
demonstration of what you're talking
about because people when they were
employees and you've been one so you
know this inherently subconsciously have
to have some level of fear base in them
that the company maybe not telling you
the truth it's just the inherent human
nature of the employee or employee
relationship and so the reaffirming the
mission or what you're trying to
accomplish even if it's super simplistic
oh yeah is oftentimes not not consumed
because one has to worry about
themselves as an employee and is always
worried that the other shoe might drop I
mean it's crazy
even when you're trying to be as clear
as possible right clarity is one of our
values because we're dealing in a
business that's considered really
intentionally opaque and we're trying to
change all that but like we at every All
Hands show the whole business the
company how many boys or don't know
we're about 35 it's awesome it's really
it's a fun time
what about firing somebody that's
[ __ ] hard yeah was that hard for you
it was initially because I didn't know
how to do it well right but I feel like
if you're good at managing expectations
and setting really clear goals
then by the time you have to have that
conversation with someone that are
that's about them parting ways with you
like they should already know it
shouldn't be a surprise and it shouldn't
be a hard conversation yeah I would
argue that I'm still not great at it and
I was borderline atrocious at it the
first 15 to 16 years of my career I just
hated it how'd you get better
AJ helped when AJ came to Vayner when I
started with AJ he was much better at it
than me with candor which i think is the
main part to what you're talking about
just just wanting to be better you know
just realizing like this was one of the
flaws of my system then I would shock
people like it's nice to make it lovely
and bubbly and awesome 24/7 365 but if
the with if the movie ends with you
firing them and they're flabbergasted
because you've given them no negative
feedback that's not good and I just had
to get to that place where I was like
just had to get to that place where I
realized it was one of my weaknesses
have you ever tried to get someone back
be fired no because I desperately don't
want to fire like I really like it's
awfully hard to get fired and Gary land
like you really are in D and F land
around either your skillset or your
personality and how you affect everybody
else so no I've never tried to get
anybody who I in the history of my life
I've never tried to refire rehire
somebody I fired I've tried to get
people back and have left right but even
that's been remarkably rare but yeah
that was a real struggle for me what
about what about somebody who's great at
their job but is not nice to the other
boys and girls how much of a challenge
has that been with making a decision
based on culture versus output of skill
yeah and what do you sit on that
currently I have no tolerance for that
okay so we had someone who was an
incredibly talented person in their job
but was emotionally abusive yeah and
like
had to part ways with them because how
long did you sit on it and how long did
you work on it so that's a great
question the persons with the company
for just about a year when did you
become aware of like oh well when they
started reporting to me interesting
because when they because they had
previous bosses they were two layers
below and those people sheltered that
mm-hmm
and I had heard Inklings yep but I had
an experience at firsthand yep and when
I did it was like I have no tolerance
for this and so did you try to reform or
was it because you had Inklings you kind
of knew was in the air and you were like
[ __ ] it this is the affirmation
affirmation I don't really need to sit
on it I think I moved within 72 hours
what about the industry itself like
how's the competitive landscape how is
that helping artists yeah no I think
it's really exciting time there's so
many different partners for artists you
get their music out there right we know
about the major labels but there's all
these self-serve platforms companies a
district hit in tune chord
I love Punk that's awesome who's the
best I think he's a great human he's
someone who I talked you guys cross over
a lot or you competitive you know what
it's funny there's the cruise wounded up
people who assume people a student that
we're really competitive with each other
and because the products are competitive
not really like you know the cliche like
overlap totally what do you think you'll
overlap on 50% of the things 30% less
and less so we are not his user base is
a lot of both hobbyists and artists who
are up-and-coming
Mars are re focus is really an artist
who either have established management
teams around them or are further in
their career cycles I say so there might
be a little bit of overlap in there few
days like I don't know there's
preferences right some people just like
this one not exactly if you want to pay
a flat fee or subscription and you don't
really mean much support with an Account
Manager he's an amazing service yeah if
you want a bit more hands-on strategy
support and you want to have an
ecosystem around you and you're
collaborating with established
songwriters and producers we need to get
paid you need help navigating publishers
like we do that are you being used by
managers and others like are you a b2b
function to a lot of things maybe to be
function takes sense yep so we are
embedded within a lot of the big
management companies like red light
grok nation full-stop etc and I think
that's where we came into the market was
when I realized there was an open spot
there were all these services that were
serving the longtail or DIY or the major
labels had their offerings for clients
who wanted a major label but if you were
an up-and-coming artist that had a
manager that represented the migos or
future someone like that and you were
up-and-coming you weren't ready for a
major label what was the best service
for them to use cuz they needed to get
someone on the phone you don't wanted to
have a partner that can collaborate with
but they didn't want to give up 30% and
so we came up with an offering that we
thought was really hitting a sweet spot
that was open in the market interesting
what is what's take it up even higher
level what do you think is interesting
about music and creators right now in
general State of the Union to bring the
most value to everybody listening I
think that the form of music and the
purpose of music has so much more than
it ever has right let's talk about tick
tock for a second right so the purpose
of music back in the day was about
education storytelling saying something
and expressing yourself that other
people can't put into words which is why
you listen to songs you have that
emotional attachment because someone's
saying something that you can't feel you
can't express I mean you feel if you
can't express it with things like tick
tock in YouTube right music has taken a
shape in which people can make it their
own and make it the soundtrack of their
lives and so video on YouTube has been a
place for music to break through because
people were able to share music video
content of their own type not high
production quality like things went
viral because of the dances people were
doing whether it was saying Lantos I'm
blinking on and what was it called the
song addy did I'm not sure the dance oh
my god don't worry good news everyone's
gonna leave comments about what it is
keep going I'm sure you'll remember it
all hit me in a second I know about the
broom challenge well that's obviously
care about today right there's all these
songs that went broke because people
were recording their own videos home
videos and posting it with your
background and with tik-tok it took the
shorter version of that so we're seeing
things blow up on tick-tock because
people are able to use the songs 15
second clip as like the loop and make a
video to it and so it's an exciting
time because now if you're a musician
you're thinking about how do I want how
do I want people to consume my music and
what's the best place for me to launch
it on yeah I understand I should that's
exciting and what about what about
creators cuz we focused on music a
little bit but I'm interested in you're
like take on creator revenue splits or
like what's how strategic are the top
5,000 creators getting with you know
collabs and things of that nature I mean
that's the best way that's the best way
to grow no you collapse right it's the
way that you grow your audience its show
do you agree with each other exactly so
I think it's exciting and I think that
the flexibility in the deal-making
that's happening behind the scenes is
enabling things like this took her the
friction starting to go away which was
exciting you asked me earlier like
what's the thing I was the most
surprised by to learn yeah it's about so
I had this realization this year we
started sitting down with a lot of
artists who started on stem and we're
getting pursued by major labels and the
major labels were putting these insane
deals in front of them with like huge
cash upfront advances and the way that
recoupment works in the business is
[ __ ] crazy but we can talk about that
separately and so when I would look at
these deals I would say to the artists
do you know what you're giving up and
they'd say well my manager is helping me
navigate the jail terms with my lawyer
my business manager and I say okay has
anyone built you a financial model like
you know how much money you're making
right now cuz your self distributing how
much money are you going to give up over
time to pay this back and by the way are
you ever going to pay back like will you
see another dollar after this big
advance and what blew me away is that
when an artist is negotiating terms
between two different offers or looking
at any offer no one rates in a financial
model like no one does whether it's an
up-and-coming artist or someone who's
huge that's established that's
renegotiating their deals
could you imagine taking an investment
for your business without seeing a pro
forma of course not like how do you know
what you're gonna do without knowing how
much you're giving up so when you're
showing them that like cool you're
getting this check but F why do you
realize that you would have actually
made this money in 27 months and then
own your own [ __ ] and keep making money
versus never again it becomes a very
different conversation yeah
it completely does and I think people
don't understand what a what these deal
terms mean right like the most artist
friendly deal is considered a 50-50 net
profit it's like a JV right like I'm
putting up the money you and I are gonna
be partners we're gonna share the
profits right it sounds amazing yeah
except back in the day there was
actually risk for these labels because
you really didn't know now they're not
signing people until the markets been
established for them anyway it's super
easy for them to hedge against the
downside completely and they're
underwriting the risk the same way for
someone who's proven a bit of traction
for somebody to be amazing these are
obvious before they sign right and they
have historical revenue that you can
look at to underwrite and they just
don't
it's a bidding war yep and so you know
we announced earlier this year a program
called a stem check just because I was
so frustrated that I saw people taking
deals that they don't understand and the
purpose of the stem track is it's open
office hours come sit with my finance
team I hired amazing people from
companies like SpaceX and Yahoo Finance
and other firms that are really well
established with strong teams come bring
your deal terms they'll look at them or
even just tell them hypothetical deal
terms we'll look at your rep and you
will build you a model so you could at
least see what it means to give a 50
percent 30 percent 70% and how does it
look like when your recouping against
the gross not yours okay are the labels
starting to understand that they need to
provide more value than distribution or
still not yet oh yeah I think they're
realizing that you know they need to
bring these services in-house I think
one of the biggest changes was Napster
and people talk about it because it
created new platforms but what people
forget is that when Napster blew up the
music business people dropped all of
their shared services so the freelance
people who did radio marketing that were
once employed by the major labels are no
longer employed it's only been Napster
that was more of a share bear user I
still like share bear was my Napster
just that was a shout-out to all the 90s
tech kids keep going
so all these radio promo people that you
think are only hired by hire Bowl
because they're employees of the record
label are actually freelancer so if you
have money
higher than two so at this point I think
major labels for the most part are big
banks of course they're really expensive
right of course they do distribution but
you don't need a label for distribution
anymore no there's something called the
Internet yeah but what you do still need
and I think this is really rare is an
aien are like that person who has a
vision for you right like bringing it
back to the Jimmy Iovine days so some
more Vince McMahon right like some sees
you and like knows how to package and
merchandise you in an authentic way to
you instead of making you do something
you're not and take it from there yeah
because that's a real partnership right
raw natural talent development but they
can't do that when they're signing
thousands of artists ear mm-hmm
so you know knowing that when we look at
our business so if you're if you're
talking to your hypothetical sister who
happens to be the next next Billy Eilish
like yeah and she's coming up what do
you say to her how do you see it like
what if she's like hey honey what should
I do
like well like give me the blueprint
what is your personal opinion yeah
obviously you've built a company around
parts of it but there's a little bit
more to that which is why I'm asking
what do you tell her depends on what you
think you're capable of and what you
need right what are the jobs that you
need done you know what you know well
fair enough but I think what's most
interesting is that everybody at that
stage reverse engineers from I want to
be the biggest star in the world yeah
but you can get to being the biggest
around the worlds if you have the right
team around you right but there's some
people who don't know how to put that
team together who don't want to manage
that team most and so that's okay go to
a place that'll do it for you but if
you're someone like a chance the rapper
or a Frank Ocean or someone who has the
ability to have a team around them and
all you need is just tools and money
there's great options for you to go get
that on your own and how do you think
that's playing out for non musicians a.k
creators on tick tock and YouTube and
other platforms don't mean they're
saying there there's a difference right
like we saw MC ends which word the
equivalent of record labels and they all
fell apart well they were all over
leverage then got overvalued right but
they weren't really sustainable but oh
but I mean I think the question becomes
it's like director consumer brands right
yeah most fail when things being favored
nor overvalued so extreme and people are
taking cash off the table that's just
financial arbitrage sure we
and then you have founders and a lot of
those MC ends have that scenario where
once you make that big payday the energy
of building it goes to a different place
because now you want to buy a boat or a
nice house in the hills instead of
actually building something meaningful
forever to your point the theory of it
MCN or a theory of a manager or an agent
or a platform can play out if it
continues to bring value to the end-user
it can you're right right do you see do
you see a lot of these people just
becoming insular businesses themselves
aka when you know two to three
meaningful tools around them and then
six or seven meaningful humans around
them and that's the game yeah I mean
that's where you see a lot of the big
management companies were built off the
back of a big artist right red light was
built off the back of Dave Matthews Band
rock nation was built on the back of Jay
Z so you start building a team around an
artist in-house and then you start
signing more artists because you now
have a team raction skin so absolutely
and I think that the new all the
services that our record label used to
provide a lot of that work is happening
inside of a management company now I
think that's right so what what didn't
we turn out as wrapping up like what
yeah what else do you want to talk about
so the thing we're gonna announce soon
that I'm excited about is that we just
partnered with a firm called co-venture
and we weren't sure and we raised 100
million dollars to invest in artists
explain so I think that we talked about
how predatory the nature of many
advances are mm-hmm and we want to be
able to not only educate artists about
what they're giving up but also offer an
alternative right so because this
because the deals are bad you can go in
between bad and zero and and make them
what you deem as the best alternative to
the reality the marketplace yeah yeah
we're fairly priced capital and what I
think is yet well yeah it makes sense
but it's but it's meant to be more than
just like a fairly priced how do you
know it's fair right well you have to
know how much are you taking out how
much do you have to pay back and how
long is he gonna take you
in essence historically like the best
money lenders of all time built the
biggest punk companies in the world
which is how do you
more aligned with the person that's
taking the money yeah why why did banks
do a better job than loan sharks it was
better for the person taking the money
and not only can you get the money but
you can also get the resources with us
understood smart money smart money money
that scales and we're calling it scale
and so what this is your play into like
is this a payback model where you're in
the financial or are you trying to
actually have a three percent of the
back end of mmm no I don't want any
back-end I want if you want to take if
you're making 10 grand a month off your
music on stem you are shared by that way
yep you can take around a hundred
thousand dollars I'd say and you can
decide do you want to pay it off with a
hundred percent of your revenue every
month or do you need five K in your
pocket to pay your rent and other expand
your making a few against the money well
you're contributing whatever you want
depending on how much you want to
contribute will determine how quickly
you paid down so the faster you pay down
the smaller the fee I understand and so
you as the arbiter prepare for you in a
standpoint because you have the math of
what they're doing on stem you guys have
a clean data set which allows you to
give away money at low risk and the
lower the risk is the lower percentage
you charge them based on how fast they
pay back and so you're just they make
sense and we're in the collection flow
right the money comes your car business
I don't it's a credit card business well
you know with a lot of data you'll have
a really good sense of like how risky
the advances you're giving aren't you
make small percentages in the scheme
versus the big percentages that the
labels are doing yeah and I actually
believe that an artist doesn't have to
take that big check upfront they should
be taking and we're incentivizing them
with the model to take the money they
need right now because it's a line of
credit they can take more overtime and
the labels and others will still be in
business because some people are
impatient and the thought of a two
million dollar check still excites them
even though it's a bad deal and the
alignment with a big brand like a
universal or later scoper atlantic well
tell your homies back at home like I
signed this deal
yeah so it's brand and maybe the glitz
of a bigger deal which is less practical
than something that's a little bit more
financially responsible yeah and you
listen there's always two who make those
decisions right yeah there's somebody
right now would just borrow money paying
40% interest to some very shady person
that's gonna break their neck if they
don't pay back in a hundred days that's
real life that happens totally does
but illegal song
of God but he's still here he always
pulls it out in the end but I think that
for a person to start thinking about
their business and in terms of how much
money am I taking and what does it mean
that I have to pay back is a concept
that people in music just haven't
thought about it that way like you know
about hey there's no fee it's a present
and that's crazy to me that's awesome so
we're excited about that
good for you thank you good to see you
yeah where can people check out the
platform stem is is mm-hmm is that
Israel uh what's ah yes
I sign baby dot comps I like that we do
know my available if we didn't know the
song we don't know that is it nice
it is Israel I don't think so either
it's not Israel Israel's I all I think I
think you're right this is sweet stem is
thought about it no it was too [ __ ]
expensive so it's still being used I
still can't get it [ __ ]
I know right one day one day I'm not
stirring after this new launch does
extremely well filet right love it good
to see you thank you thank you
you